[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this time tomorrow you were back in
sober living yeah okay you did not leave
my sight ever because for the next 24
hours you are mine all mine
got it I got it he burns I thought you
were dead
I put my family in danger this is on you
if I don't deal with this then it could
be worse next time okay
you go in pay the man and get right back
out lock the door
[Music]
Celeste come on everybody's downstairs
it's a weird world we live in and the
way I've chosen to live my life don't
follow goes against some people's views
on things
do you want to give a quick picture with
you mom I'm worried about you you're
worried about me Queen Elizabeth your
cousin mary has returned to take up her
throne in Scotland the Queen how did the
world come to this wise men servicing
the whims of women you would do well to
watch or while I will not be scolded by
my inferior your very
are you afraid Henry no good because our
swords are not just for sure we have a
scourge upon our land
there's a woman with a crowd
[Music]
[Applause]
nothing could stand in the face of this
we are loved
we'll give
[Music]
my name is Peter Parker I'm pretty sure
you know the rest I saved the city fell
in love then I saved the city again and
again and again look I'm a comic-book
serial to get a Christmas album and it's
so so popsicle but this isn't about me
not anymore
so you want to learn to be spider-man
Keeney teach me yes I can time to swing
remember what makes you different
let's go
is what makes you spider-man
officer I love you wait he should come
have fun ease baby I hope is the boy
come on over here daughter you're a good
girl and I'm proud of you don't you ever
forget it and who's gonna be responsible
for this baby the father and the mother
but I want you in Mom's I got all my
baby in the house finally that child was
born of seeing a cow
it's your grandchild what difference
does it make how it gets here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
MARY POPPINS you came back you seemed
hardly to have aged at all really one
never discusses a woman's age Michael
would have hoped I taught you better do
what
[Music]
everything is possible if it be
impossible
[Music]
Oh freak out
[Music]
to be terrible about things they don't
understand from now on only person you
can show yourself around is me oh good
now I'm good thanks
there's a war raging on our planet
if this criminal isn't found that war
may find its way so anyone that can help
you or the family
Oh
permission to come aboard brother King
arm is about to declare war on the
surface world
the only way to stop this war is for you
to take your rightful place as king
trust me
I don't you do your best thinking when
you're not thinking at all that was the
worst pep talk ever a world war two
illustrator and now I can barely write
my name I heard what happened to you
five of them jumped him to miracle II
survive but I've created a world where I
can heal what is all of this
welcome tomorrow these are the women of
Marwan and they protect mark we're one
on the same towel from the bad guys
let's go
I thought I heard you yelling for more
gumbo not gumbo no gumbo to life to love
to the women of Marwin Obama I gave you
a completely new identity you said you
wanted to be fancy so I just like
Cinderella's your ass well I got you in
the door you've got the job baby who's
the champ let's go
who's the champ on the tail you're the
you're the champ it's not easy getting a
job for a woman your age
Oh watch me imma be on okay oh yeah um
inshallah yo G suddenly gone mom she
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
Your Majesty may I present to you the
greatest detective of all time
Sherlock Holmes
and dr. John Watson
I love you Oh Oh what - look out right
[Music]
I have two days left to live majesty
would you mind if we had a picture
together
who's going to take the photograph I
will take it you see it's sort of a self
photograph he's a real fan I swear I
never do this I want you to be my VP
well George honey I'm a CEO a large
company and I have been Secretary of
Defense and I have been White House
chief of staff the vice presidency is a
mostly symbolic job however if we came
to a different understanding what we're
seeing bureaucracy military energy
and foreign policy
so we gonna do this thing whatever is
this happening I believe we can make
this work which one makes me look more
like a Harvard man I'm Ruth Bader
Ginsburg and why are you here miss
Ginsburg occupying a place that could
have gone to a man there are hundred and
seventy-eight loss a different shape on
the basis of second convinced the courts
that those laws are unconstitutional who
know read text quick cases
read this from the law assumes a
caregiver has to be a woman this is
sex-based discrimination against a man
so judge was wrong
mr. Mart's the law is wrong we all must
take these laws on one by one is to
topple the whole damn system of
discrimination
[Music]
who is it no ID no idea
look right enough next to a guy
we do this we accept the cousin just
chose to play cops and robbers
you lost
[Music]
I'm an I'm still mad it's burned a
circuit in my brain
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]